hey everyone welcome to another episode
of unlocking lily I believe that this
world would be a better place if we all
just embrace who we truly are evan is
currently my
mentor and he's helping me build my
business around my speaking and coaching
and I am so excited to have all of you
guys join me on my startup journey guys
I'm freaking out because I'm moving to
Thailand and I can't believe it's
actually happening the original plan was
for me to move to Mexico and work
remotely there and it was a really safe
thing for me to do was a little bit
scary but it was safe because I was
still in the same timezone Estolano and
I was only a three and a half hour plane
ride away from heaven but I've decided
to make a very heart centered decision
to move to Thailand with someone I met
only twice in person in my entire life
and the reason for that is that I feel
like this is the right thing for me to
do and it's so hard for me to explain I
have only seen him twice in my entire
life but yet I feel like I know him so
well
I feel like this is a leap into the
unknown that I really want to take with
him now he could be crazy and we could
hate each other and within the first two
days I might want to come back home or
this could be the greatest experience of
my life and this could be the greatest
love that was ever written in the book
of Lilly but there's no way of me
knowing until I actually do the thing
and following my heart and trusting the
unknown is something that I've been
wanting to do for a very long time and
the reason for that is this is that I
teach my clients I always teach my
client yes it's scary it's being scary
to leave everything to chance in the
unknown but nothing is ever guaranteed
and if you try to guarantee everything
and control everything first of all it's
really not fun and secondly there's no
such thing
right so I decided that I need to do
this thing he was moving to Thailand oh
boy you know I'm gonna follow there with
you because I want to be with you I want
to find out how it's like to actually
live with you and spend time with you
because all I know from him is a lot of
online correspondence
I don't really actually know how he is
physically except for the two times I've
seen him and now this could be a
complete dark damp heartbreaking
disaster or it could be the greatest
love that was ever written in my book or
it's somewhere in between
either way I'm okay with it not working
out and completely hitting the fan but
what I'm not okay with is never knowing
it's living the rest of my life feeling
like what could have been of my life if
I actually went to Thailand with him and
actually try to see if we're even a good
fit can we even live together there's no
way of me knowing unless I actually do
it you know guys the reality is you're
only one decision away from completely
changing your life around and this is
that decision for me making that
decision in a split second this was
something that I had not planned and I
just said yes let's just make this
happen
it's gonna completely change my life
either way is going to change my life
whether if it works out it doesn't work
out or somewhere in between it's going
to be a life-changing experience for me
now
as much as I want to leave things to the
unknown and follow my heart and not live
my life in regret there are actual real
concerns that need to be addressed in my
business my biggest concern right now is
that my business is going to fail and
there's a real possibility that it might
when Evan and I first got together to
create this business
that intention was for me to be mentored
by him in person
in Toronto and then eventually that
ended up being possibly going to Mexico
and now to Thailand Mexico was a safe
choice it's not that far away it's the
time zones are the same now I'm gonna go
go to Thailand it's a 12 hour time zone
difference it's thousands of miles away
it's 20 plus some what hours and plane
ride actually don't know I think that's
what it is and there's a real danger
that I may completely lose myself over
there I don't know anything I just know
this person that I've seen twice in my
entire life in person so it's a major
concern and I'm so worried I'm so
worried that this million dollar
business I thought I plan to succeed in
is not going to happen because I decided
to follow my heart I'm scared that not
having Evan around physically is going
to hurt my business I'm scared that I'm
gonna lose myself as an entrepreneur I'm
gonna lose my sense of self because now
I'm completely removed from the North
American culture but what I know is that
I need to trust myself and the logistics
and the solutions is going to happen so
regarding the mentoring relationship
with Evan we've decided that we're gonna
continue to keep our Monday timeslot so
every single Monday I meet with him from
10:00 a.m. to 12:00 p.m. Eastern
Standard Time it's once a week that I
meet with him I think I could stay awake
on will be Tuesday nights Tuesday
mornings in Thailand and make the
timezone work we have constant
correspondence I could I could have him
email me I can email him there's lots of
different ways that we could continue
our mentorship and the idea behind it is
it's not the whole logistics that matter
is that I need to trusted myself that
this is actually going to happen and I
need to trust Evan that he has enough
confidence in me and believes in me
enough that we're still going to make
this business work the second concern
that I have is my clients right now I
have ongoing clients that meet with me
at a very specific time every single
month and that's based on Eastern
Standard Time
it's scary for me because now I have to
make those tons of work they're so used
to meeting me at a certain time and
that's been the intention and the
expectation since I started with them
and I'm so worried I'm not yes I'm
worried about the time zone but what I'm
even more concerned about is I never I
never want my clients to feel like
they're second-best to me just because
I'm following my heart and I'm following
this guy that I may or may not love not
joking I actually do really love him I
don't want any one of my clients to feel
like they're not loved by me that that
I'm not there for them I and that isn't
a really big concern for me that I have
to figure out this time zone thing and
that time zone thing really is just a
reflection of the fact that I'm afraid
that I won't be able to deliver value
for people that people are going to
think that I've forgotten about them the
reality is I have not I have not
forgotten about my clients so the
solution to that is that I am going to
try to figure out the scheduling try to
figure out the Eastern Standard Time and
also the biggest thing is for me to be a
hundred percent transparent with all my
clients I have to let them know that I'm
moving to Thailand guys and the time
zone is gonna be a little bit for the
first little while and I'm also gonna be
a little up in the first couple weeks
because I don't
place to stay yet so I need to be a
hundred percent transparent with them
and yeah maybe some of them might not be
able to deal with my crazy and my
chaotic mess and constant following
their hardness and they might leave and
they might drop off right
the default always is just think oh no
it's gonna be fine don't worry no
sometimes it's not gonna be fine some
people are gonna take offense to that
and leave me as their coach because they
want to deal with my and that's okay too
but that's their choice right I have to
do everything I can to make the timezone
work to make the coaching sessions work
and be a hundred percent transparent and
let my clients know that I'm still there
for them regardless of where I am on
this planet and the third thing I'm
afraid of is losing myself in this
country what if I decide this is really
scared for me what if I decide like this
business I'm just going to travel the
world for the next year with the sky and
become a housewife or something which
will never happen but it could happen
and I'm so afraid that I'm gonna
completely lose myself in this I'm gonna
lose myself in the culture I'm gonna
forget about my business that I worked
so hard towards and means that the world
to me
I'm worried I'm worried I'm gonna change
so much that I'm not even gonna be able
to recognize myself and to be honest
with you I don't have a solution to that
yet I don't I don't know I don't know
how I'm gonna change when I get there I
really don't but what I do know is this
whatever decision that I make whatever
choice that I make I know that I trust
myself to meet the
decision and it will always be the best
decision for me and feeling that feeling
that I know what's right for me and I
know what's best for me is really giving
me the courage to actually do this to
actually step into the unknown and
travel thousands of miles away with
someone I've only met twice in person is
scary but I trust myself the trust is
not in him the trust is in me the trust
is not in the place a trust is a mean
and that's what I have to constantly
come back at all the solutions all the
logistics and all the technical things
that I can do to make this happen none
of that could actually happen if I don't
trusted myself and that's the most
important thing the best decision is the
decision you make for yourself and you
have to trust that it's going to work
and have a special shudder from Mike
from chart your trade might thank you so
much for being there for me and I love
you thank you guys so much for watching
and more importantly being on this
journey with me it's so crazy how I
started off as a speaker then became a
coach and then moved to the country the
move to the city possibly moving to
Mexico and now moving to Thailand and it
feels so amazing in knowing that all of
you guys aren't there for me every step
of so thank you guys so much again and
I'll see you guys very very soon if you
tell yourself a story long enough you
start to believe it won't you believe it
you act like it I have the Tulsa what a
wail out of handcuffed lightning though
Thunder in jail now you know I'm bad
over the last week I murdered a rock
into the stone hospitalized a brick I'm
so mean I make medicine sick
the fundamental key to success is it can
take between eighteen and two hundred
and fifty-four days of taking action for
a new habit to stick I've created a new
course called 254 confidence or every
single day for 254 days I will be
sending you a video between thirty
seconds and five minutes long that you
start your morning with around making
you feel confident it's absolutely free
check out the link in the description
below to get access